all right well
um yeah so it's a little something a
little different mind expanding is a
good word for it
um so the title my talk is computing
like the brain
uh about 30 years ago when i was a young
man
i fell in love with brains and i was
inspired by an article by francis crick
who uh of dna fame who wrote an article
in a single issue topic a single topic
issue in science of american about the
brain he said
he said look we have all this data about
the brain all these facts and
knowledge but we have no idea how it
works and he says what we're missing is
some sort of broad framework of ideas in
which to interpret neuroscience
results and we basically was a data-rich
and theory-poor field and i said
boy working on brains and figuring how
brains work would be the greatest thing
to do what an important thing
what an exciting thing and i dedicated
my life to it
and um it was very difficult to do and
so i had a few stints in the mid-80s
where i was a graduate student working
full-time for a few years but
it was very hard to to get get a gig
working full-time doing neuroscience
theory
um so actually i ended up started palm
in handspring for a few years and well
15 years
and now for the last 10 years almost 11
years now i've been doing it full-time
first at the redwood neuroscience
institute
which is now at berkeley i ran that for
several years and now at numenta
so i'm going to tell you about what
we've been doing and the exciting
progress we've been making
i started out 30 years ago i gave myself
two tasks
first was to answer francis crick's call
which was to discover the principles
of the operation of the neural cortex uh
now i'm going to
talk mostly about the neocortex today
and i'll come back to that in a moment
but
this this idea that we could figure out
how the brain works so the information
principles by which
by which it works a lot of people
thought that was crazy back then
some people still do but not too many um
and then i think as soon as you figure
how this works you could build machines
that work on those principles
and that was exciting too because i
realized we could build machines that
are faster and more intelligent and
bigger and all kinds of cool things
than humans are and so boy this would be
a great thing to do so the basic process
is the following you start with
with anatomy and physiology of the brain
because the brain provides a whole set
of constraints
and there's a ton of stuff that's known
about the brain it's hard to imagine how
many papers are published every year and
how much data we have
that's been unassimilated by theory so
we have this all this detail about
anatomy and physiology
and those are constraints on what the
theoretical principles are going to work
because you have to start there
then you can decide you can you can add
a little bit of math a little bit of
information theory and you come up with
these principles
and once you can do that then you can
implement them you can start with
software so you can model the principles
in software
and that's where we are today we're
starting to do that and i'm going to
demonstrate some of that today
ultimately this is going to go into
other implementations such as silicon
and there's some terrible conversations
that are going on right now between
myself and then to some other companies
along those lines so here's the agenda
for my talk
i'm going to tell you a little bit about
the brain i'm going to describe uh the
near cortez is a predictive modeling
system
i'm going to talk about three of the
principles that are that are used in it
um sparse distributed representation
sequence memory and online learning
i'm then going to briefly introduce a
product called grock which
implements this it's a predictive
modeling product and then i'm going to
speculate a little bit about the future
of intelligent machines
okay so let's just jump uh right into it
here
um so the neocortex just just to make
sure you understand that you know if you
took a brain human brain
the big wrinkly thing on top is the
neocortex it's about
60 of the volume of your brain and it's
where all high level intelligence
resides so my
my speech is being generated by my
neurocortex you're understanding my
speech is being interpreted by union
cortex
all vision all high level uh auditory
motor planning and so on there's a lot
of other stuff the brain does but the
neurocortex is where
really intelligence resides and you can
think about the neocortex but you have
to you have to think about it in terms
of the senses
you know we have a lot of senses not
just the five we think about the three
major ones vision touch and hearing
are actually multiple senses but the
thing you need to understand about them
is they're not
single senses the retina is an array of
senses it's actually a million senses
there's a million fibers or neurons that
are projected from your optic
on your optic nerve and so it's an it's
an array of a million sensors
the auditory uh nervous 30
000 and the somatic uh senses uh are
about another million and they're arrays
so
your brain has several million senses
actually
and the data changing on them is changed
on the order of a few milliseconds tens
of milliseconds or hundreds of
milliseconds
and so you have this fire hose of data
coming into the brain
the entire waking life and that's all
that the brain has to work with
and what it does is it builds a model of
the world
when you're born your neocortex has
structure
but it doesn't know anything it doesn't
know about opera houses doesn't know
about alex miller it doesn't know about
computers it doesn't know about coffee
cups it doesn't know about street cars
it doesn't know about anything it
doesn't know a language doesn't know
math
doesn't know any computer languages you
have to learn all that stuff it has to
be learned through
your senses so the brain builds a model
of the world of what's
in the world and how they relate to it
another is obviously a very
sophisticated
model and it has a tremendous capacity
the number of things you know
is really amazing although you're not
even aware of most of it
most of it's subconscious this model
that the brain does then when
when you have new sensory input it
invokes the model that's when you
perceive this stage and perceive me
talking you're mostly invoking
a model you already have so sort of a
partial this data comes in and
invokes a model and from that model you
can think of doing three basic things
it makes predictions about what's going
to happen next
um detects anomalies and generates
behaviors the predictions you're not
generally aware of but your brain is
constantly predicting what you're going
to see
feel and touch or hear so if i put my
hand on this lectern
i've never stood in this place before my
brain has expectation what it's going to
feel like if it felt
metal or cold or like liquid i would be
very surprised if
my hand passed through it i'd be
surprised so every touch everything
you're doing every
word i say your brain has expectations
about what's going to be what it's going
to
see it's making predictions constantly
and when those predictions are violated
it detects something's wrong it's an
anomaly
and finally it generates actions every
part of the neocortex is generating
actions like my speech right now
so we want to understand how this thing
works uh and it's a memory system so
unlike my title my talk i say computing
like the brain the brain doesn't compute
it's a memory system
it's a very unusual memory system and so
we're going to talk about how that works
here's the i'm going to tell you the top
three there's sev many principles i can
tell you about let me give you the top
three principles
that um i think of when i think about
how the new cortex works
the first of all it's a hierarchy so
even though it's a sheet of cells
um the different parts of that sheet are
different regions they seem to do
different things but they're connected
physically as a hierarchical system
and i've drawn a little caricature
drawing of it here um
and so you have these regions that
project the regions predictive regions
so inputs come from your senses
they converge on the first set of
regions and then they can converge and
converge and
up up the hierarchy information blows
back down the hierarchy
diverging as it goes back down too now
the amazing thing about this hierarchy
is that in
your near cortex is that all the regions
in the new york cortex appear to be
doing the same thing
so the different regions in the
hierarchy the different sensory
modalities are all the same thing it's
there's
one memory algorithm that works on
vision hearing touch
um and all the all the senses that come
into the brain and so we have a
hierarchy of similar
uh um uh memory uh regions and we wanna
understand how the hierarchy works
um the next thing is uh what's going on
in each of those regions
well this is memory as i mentioned uh
the primary memory not the only type of
memory but the primary memory is
sequence memory
this may not be obvious to you it wasn't
obvious to me for many years
um but you basically the way you build a
model the world is by viewing
getting patterns through time so
obviously my
my neocortex is generating my speech
right now and it's
it's passing to the muscles in my voice
box very complex temporal patterns it's
playing back patterns that it's stored
before i've said these words before
maybe not in this exact order
and you are interpreting these things in
time so the only way you can understand
my speech is you have to have a memory
of what words and phrases and concepts
sound in sequence and time
the order and the timing is very
important and you have to have you have
to have sequence memory to do this
well turns out that's even how vision
works and so on it it's all sequence
memory and we understand how that works
and the third major principle i'm going
to talk about today is the type of
representations used in the brain
and these we call sparse distributor
representations uh they're sparse
because if you look in the brain
everywhere you look you see a bunch of
cells
many many cells there's about 30 billion
cells in your neocortex
at any point in time a very small subset
are active at just a few percent
and so it's a sparse representation it
turns out this is essential to the way
the whole thing works
um it's even sparse coming off your
senses so when you look at the
activation on your auditory nerve or
your or your
optic nerve it's a sparse activation
there so it's sparse activations
between and the memory itself is of
sparse activations
and that's something we're going to
really need to dig into in this talk
so in this talk i'm not going to talk
more about hierarchy i'm going to talk
mostly about some
big advances we made three years ago and
that has to do with the sequence memory
and sparse distributed representations
so instead of looking at the entire
neocortex in the whole hierarchy we're
just going to look at one little small
section
and sort of figure out what how's that
dealing with sparse distributed
representations and how is that learning
sequences
all right so we're going to jump right
into it into sparse distributed
representations
so what is a sparse interpreter
representation you can compare it to
what we use typically in computers which
are sometimes called dense
representations so let's start with
what we do in computers a dense
representation is
uh we typically use eight or 64 bits
something like that
it's dense because we use all
combinations of ones and zeros so ascii
is a perfect example of this it's eight
bit code
all combinations of ones and zeros are
valid um from all zeros
all ones and anything in between uh the
individual bits
in an ascii code don't really mean
anything so if i ask you what is the
what's the meaning of the third bit and
ascii code it doesn't really mean much
you might be able to come up with
something but it really has no inherent
meaning
and the other thing is that the codes we
use in computers are somewhat arbitrary
they're assigned by us the programmers
um and they don't have no inherent
meaning in the hardware itself that is
you can put you know you can come up
with a different code for you know
unicode or whatever you want for
encoding things and and it's up to us to
decide that and the computer doesn't
really know anything about it
when you get to brains and sparse
distributed representations
we can look at it this way a sparse
distributed representations or sdrs
um have thousands of bits a minimum
and they're sparse because at any point
in time only a few are active so
typically in our work we use
two percent activation so we have uh if
in our typical example for us we'll have
2
000 bits it's kind of about the small
side of things and we'll have two
percent of those bits active so we'll
have 41s and 1960 zeros
and we're always going to be sparse
always going to be like that you'll
never have a lot of bits active at once
now these are big big numbers of course
big vectors
but you can of course represent a lot of
things by choosing 40 out of 2000
um now the difference here is that each
bit has some meaning each bit can
actually has its own independent
semantic meaning
these are learned these are not assigned
they're learned
but when i want to represent something
in the brain the brain does it by
picking
the top best matches if you will
let me give you an analogy we wouldn't
do it this way but let me just give you
an analogy if i wanted to represent
uh the letters of the alphabet in a
sparse distributed representation i
might have bits
that represent is there's a vowel or a
consonant i might have bits to say is
what does it sound like is it a closed
sound open sound or a hard sound
or a fricative sound is it o sound or e
sound i might have bits that represent
how you draw it is it a closed shape an
open shape
straight lines curved lines does have
ascenders and descenders and so on
and i come up with a whole set of bits
that represent things and then i would
pick the top bits that represent this
thing
and that's my encoding my sparse
distributor encoding so each bit has
some sort of meaning
and the in the meaning of the object
themselves is encoded in the
representation
now we're not going to do it that way
this is all learned but that gives you a
sense for it
now sparse distributed representation is
some very useful properties very
interesting properties so we need to go
through those
the first one you can just think of it
this way if i have two sdrs two sparsely
stupid representations
and i can i can compare them and i and
if they have
the ones in the same locations that is
the uh in the brain of course we're
talking about cells but i'm just talking
about others that they're bits okay
um and if they have the sim common one
bits that means they have a common
they share some semantic properties so
if i see two sparsely distributed
representations
would share some bits i know immediately
they have semantic similarity
this is uh because it's very sparse is
unlikely to happen by chance
the next thing is i say what if i wanted
to store a sparse distributed
representation one i have an activation
i want to store and see if it occurs
again we do this the brand has to do
this all the time
well you don't save all 2000 bits and
stick them in some place
you just have to save indexes to the
ones and if so in this case if i had 41
bits i would have 40 index
into the thing i say now if a new
representation comes along
i go down my list of indices if i find
ones there then i know i've got a match
but what if i told you you can't store
all of them you can i'm not going to let
you store indices to all the bits but
only some subset of the bits
so let's say i say they can only store
in this is the 10 of the bits
so um you say well i said well that work
or not and you say well no it could it
could lead to an error because
i could i could i could see those 10
bits but the other 30 could be wrong
and i would be mistaken and say this is
the same same pattern i had before
mathematic is very easy to show this is
very unlikely you're going to have an
error
it's almost guaranteed you're going to
find the right thing and if you do have
an error it will be one of semantic
similarity
you'll be mistaking the input for
something that was semantically similar
to it
um in a previous time and so it's not
such a bad error if you do that
so the brain does this a lot and we're
going to take advantage of this too
this idea of sub sampling we don't need
to save if we want to recognize these
very long bit streams we only have to
save
10 20 of the bits to know where they are
check to see if they exist again
and the third property is one of union
just imagine i gave you 10 of these
sparsely stupid representations and i
ordered them together
so now you still have 2 000 bits but
instead of 2 of the bits being on i have
about 20 percent maybe a little bit less
so i have this union here now i give you
a new unknown one
and i want to know is it one of the
original ten is it a member of the
of the set that we formed the union from
and um
and what we're going to say is that if i
find ones
in the unknown which is only two percent
of the bits active if i find
corresponding ones in the
in the union i'm going to say it was a
member now you again might say well that
could be an error i could be matching up
a one from one of the uh 10 and another
one from another one of the ten another
one from the other ten and so on
but turns out mathematically it's very
very unlikely we're talking
astronomically unlikely
and so if you see this kind of match you
say yeah it's in the original membership
now why would i want to do this you'll
see in a moment when the brain makes a
prediction
it doesn't predict one thing it actually
predicts a whole bunch of things at the
same time
often sometimes it predicts one thing
sometimes you know what word is going to
be the end of the
sentence and sometimes you don't
but but the point is it makes
most of the time you're predicting
multiple things at the same time and we
want to know
if what happens is one of those things
so i can't tell you all the things i'm
predicting
i can't i can't unravel that union but i
can tell you if something did happen was
unexpected
and that's what this is used for okay
now if you're tired you were up late
last night doing some coding whatever
and you get you're dozing off you can
stop right now because the one thing i
want you to walk away from this talk if
you if there's only going to be one
thing
is that intelligent machines and the
brain but intelligent machines are going
to be built on sparsely distributed
representations this i'm certain of
this is the key to to machine
intelligence
and now we're going to talk about some
of the ways you work on them
okay i'm not going to talk about
sequence memory how do you
learn the sequences of these things and
and again
this is the key memory operation that's
going on the brain so i'm going to walk
you through a little bit of neuroscience
just to get you up to where we have to
go to explain how this works
so if i look at the near cortex and i
just zoomed in on one little section in
your question so the thin sheet of cells
here's a little picture of one little
section of a neocortex
and as is and you can see in there
there's this layer architecture going
left and right and there's so
you can see these little vertical lines
going there's a column and a layer
architecture
this we're going to zoom in on one of
the layers of the cells in here these
layers are all doing
similar things and this is my little
caricature drawing of a layer
a small layer of cells in your cortex
the little circles are our neurons
and you can see there's two basic
orientations here
the green arrow shows the column of
these cells
and what we find in the brain is that
this is very narrow common these like 30
microns wide
you find these cells that are in this
skinny little column they all have sort
of same response property to input so
you give an input and they all these
cells
respond in the same feed forward way
they all have a similar feed forward
response property
however 95 of the connections between
cells are horizontal that's represented
by the yellow
line so we have not the vast majority of
connections are across these columns
um and but we have this very strong
vertical orientation so that's what the
cells are connected like
if i zoom in and look at one of those
cells then you see a picture this is a
picture of a pyramidal cell in the brain
uh there's a classic neuron in your near
cortex
there's a cell body and there's all
these dendrites which are the branches
and there's connections on the branches
betw to other cells those are the
synapses i'm sure you've heard these
terms before
a typical neuron in the brain has
anywhere from a few thousand to fifty
thousand
uh synapses on it thousands of synapses
by the way if you've
anything you've ever heard about neural
networks in the past where they have
like these neurons which only have like
a few connections forget it there's
nothing like real neurons
real norms are very complex things so if
i zoom in one of those dendritic
segments
and here's a picture one of those
dendritic segments you can actually see
the synapses on it there's these little
dots
i don't know if you can see it in the
background apologies but on this little
segment there there's these little
spines coming off and they're called
spines
and this is where the synapses are
formed um and they're about one micron
apart along the length of the dendrite
now what we've learned in recent years
in neuroscience recent years is like 15
years
things go slower in neuroscience we
learned in the last 15 years or so
is that um when you have these synapses
arranged along the dendrites
if um if a bunch of them come active at
the same time close together so like
within a 40 micron distance you have
maybe 20 of these guys become active
then and they'll come back within a few
milliseconds or the other then it's a
very non-linear effect it generates a
spike which has a large effect on the
cell body
if those spikes arrived at different
timing or far apart they don't have
hardly any effect at all
so these these these dendritic segments
are like coincidence detectors they tech
a coincident pattern of activity on 20
to 40
connections at the same time and you've
got lots of these dendritic segments
we model this in the following way we we
these are the pictures
you're going to see me using here uh
we're modeling a little segment of the
uh of a layer of a cortex with a bunch
of cells here i'm showing a bunch of
little cubes in a
in a little stack so it's a layer with a
bunch of columns
and there's a picture on our right is
our artificial neuron how we model the
neurons
and the color dots are the synapses i'm
not going to talk about the green ones
today i'm just going to talk about the
blue ones
and those blue ones what i was just
talking about those blue dots or
connections to other cells
that arrange along a dendritic segment
and they act as coincidence detector so
in this picture you can see there's a
little circle next to one of those lines
of blue dots
that's showing a little threshold
detector meaning once i get above a
certain threshold they have a non-linear
event
i or those together so the cell
basically is looking at the ore of many
of these coincidence detectors and the
cell essentially is going to go into a
predictive state you'll see in a moment
when it when it's detecting a pattern
out there in the world on one of these
on one of these dendritic segments
so how are we going to turn this into
sequence memory so that's this is the
structure we have right now
and we want to answer the question how
does this learn sequences so
now i'm going to show you a different
picture of our sparse distributed
representation
instead of showing you ones and zeros
and we can show you these little cubes
these are like cells in the brain but
you can think of them as ones and zeros
the red ones are the ones the active
ones and
the gray ones are the zeros this is not
2 000 it's about a quarter of that just
to show you what it looks like
so but it's sparse and at any point in
time
i'll have some i won't explain how this
happens in this talk but at any point in
time i have a pattern on these cells
which is a sparse distributed
representation
and another point in time i have a
different pattern this is happening very
rapidly in your brain right now this is
going on your head
all over the place where you have these
things going on and off like this
and what we want to do is we want to
learn this sequence where you have the
sheet of cells and all these cells are
independent
what does it mean to learn a sequence
each cell does it on its own i'll show
you how this works
so um imagine this cell in the middle
here
when it becomes on you're one of these
cells when you become active you become
active from a feed forward input
something in the world maybe you become
active
what you do is you look for neighboring
cells that were active just prior to you
they were active just a moment ago and
you want to form connections to them
and that's what's happening here this
this cell in the middle that's yellow
saying okay i just became active what
was active prior to me
and i'm going to form connections to it
um and i'm showing that on the bottom
right here where we're basically forming
connections in one of those dendrites so
basically saying i'm looking for a
coincidence
of pattern now i don't need to look at
all the cells near my b i don't even
have to be
able to look at all the cells nearby i
only have to look at enough of them
maybe 10 or 15 or 20
and if i make enough connections then
i'm good enough and it's good
as if i looked at all the cells nearby
me so we actually want to form these
connections and if you do this
if every cell and every time a cell
becomes active every time a bit becomes
active
it looks around and formed connections
to the neighbors who were previously
active
then everyone is doing this all the time
and you'll get things like this
here's a here's a case where i have an
input which is the red cells these are
being driven by the feed forward input
and the yellow cells are all predictive
they're all saying hey i might be next i
might be next
now you can see there's more yellow
cells than red cells this is because in
this case we train
the the network on a very a series of
patterns like a followed by b
and a followed by c and a followed by d
so if i show it a
it's going to predict b c and d so i
have a multiple prediction going on
this is the basis of sequence memory
you've basically learned a transition
state
from one to the other and it's
distributed now the problem we have here
is that this is first order
meaning there's no history here i can't
um i couldn't learn a sequence a b
a c because the two a's would be
confused and it would just
there's no history here it's a first
order memory we need a variable or high
order memory
to make this work so the way we're going
to do that is we're going to use
columns and i will just go back to my
my drawings here with ones and zeros so
here's the sparse distributor
representation
and instead of using just one cell for
each bit
i'm going to use 10 or something like
that i'm going to use a column so here
i've shown above each bit
i've actually have 10 different cells
and
this is our column of cells and i'm
going to pick one of those cells to
represent
randomly for starts to be uh to
represent this so
i've done this and and now i've now i
have a different representation
i'm going to show the exact same sparse
distributed representation but i'm going
to pick a different set of cells in each
column
so in each column i randomly pick a one
of 10 so 9 out of 10 of these things
will be different on each one so
if you look at if i think of all those
circles of cells each one
i have a lot of cells now i have 10
times 2 000. i have 20 000.
but i now have 40 cells active in there
and
they're very different and i'm
representing this the same input in two
different ways
you can easily think about this if i
have 40 active columns i have 10 cells
per column i have 10 to the 40th ways
of representing the same input and this
is the ability to
learn very long and complex sequences
because i can repeating elements over
and over again and never get confused
if i say for example the sentence there
are too many tutus to count
i use the sound two four times in that
sentence
and hopefully you didn't confuse them
you didn't get lost to what i was
talking about
that's because each time i said the word
two at one point in your brain
at the columnar level it was
representing the same pattern but at the
cellular level it was representing it
differently each time
in sequence okay so that's the basis of
this and when you put this all together
and
i'm not going to walk you through all
the details there's some details to this
to make this work and deal with all the
edge cases and so on
but what you do when you build something
like this at any point in time you have
a
you have a bunch of cells that are being
predicted a bunch of cells have been
driven by feed forward point
and you're essentially in a state which
is a high order state of of of the
sequences in the world
and you have to trust me on this as this
is a very interesting way of building a
sequence memory
it is variable order it's uh it's
distributed meaning
you notice that there's no single place
i store the sequences
there's no single location it's it's
distributed all the elements are
are doing their own thing um it's making
multiple simultaneous predictions
it's a very high capacity memory uh the
kind of memories you build can learn
millions and millions of transitions
quite easily without getting confused
and it has some other really really cool
properties such as semantic
generalization
meaning if i learned a set of patterns
uh using one if
i had a bunch of patterns coming in and
i learned sequences of them if i now
have new patterns come in that are
semantically similar but different
semantically similar i can apply the
previous patterns or previous um
sequences to it it'll say hey this is
different but it's similar
i'm going to learn my previous knowledge
about transitions and about
pooling and things like that to and
basically allows the system to
generalize semantically which is really
what we need in brains and intelligent
machines
okay uh i'm gonna briefly i was debating
whether to cover this today so this is
the
the farthest reaches of my talk here um
i was gonna talk about requirements for
online learning
uh we have to this system has to be
online you know there's no batch
processing in the brain
right you don't you don't um you know
store up today's patterns and stick it
in a file someplace and then process it
tonight
you have to handle it as you go uh you
don't get a chance to go back and look
at it so it's an online learning system
and the problem with online learning
systems is continually learning
but you know new patterns might be noise
or there might be something important
so you don't really know so you have to
learn on everything
but you don't want to remember the noise
parts you only want to remember things
that occur again and again so basically
when you do it online learning
if a pat you have to learn all the time
but if a pattern doesn't repeat you
forget it if a pattern does repeat you
reinforce it
this is done in neuroscience and in our
models in the following way
you may you may just go back to our
little picture here of the of the
of the neurons and going all the way
over to the right we have those synapses
on the dendritic spine
and for many years um for 60 years now
people thought about neurons and
learning as the the strengthening of
connections between cells the
strengthening of synapses and certainly
that's happening
but we now know that synapses form
rapidly de novo from like i have an axon
a dendrite and there's no synapses and
in a matter of
seconds it can grow one and so it's
actually better to think about synapses
as being
formed and unformed than strengthening
and weakening
and that's how we model it and the way
we do this is the following we basically
say synapses are binary they're either
connected or they're not connected
but they have a growth or permanence
which is sort of representing how far
they've grown and how
how what their state of permanence is
and that's a scalar
so we have the scalar thing that from
zero to one and if it's above a
threshold like then we say it's
connected and if it's below the
threshold we say it's not connected
this allows me to say i can start
learning on something and incrementing
its permanence
before it has any effect on the system
it doesn't have any practical effect
because it's below the threshold
and it says once i made a connection if
i repeat these patterns over and over
again
i can make it really permanent so it's
hard to forget and so we needed to add
that to that if you add all this up just
to give you a sense what this is like
um one of our systems we typically uh
we're only
modeling a small region in a cortex we
have 2 000 columns 30 cells per column
128
dendritic segments per cell and about 40
connections per segment those are all
biologically realistic numbers at least
the last three there are and so you can
end up you just do the math it's about
300 million connections
in one of our models these connections
are very sparse
and therefore you know we don't have to
save all this stuff there's tricks we
can do
to make the memory requirements much
smaller again there are no single points
of failure in the system you can
drop out connections you can drop out
dendrites you can drop out cells you can
drop out columns
it's very everything degrades very
gracefully uh
just like in the brain okay now i'm
trying to switch
topics completely i'm not going to show
you this working in a real system
and to do that i have to um introduce
the field of which we're working at
numenta
uh beyond the neuroscience stuff so uh
we're doing the world in predictive
analytics or uh streaming data
and so i need to give you a little
background our philosophy about this so
here's the way the world looks today
we have lots of sensory data in the
world and we collect it and put it in
databases
uh and then we can go back and look at
it we have tools for doing visualization
on those databases
and we have tools for making predictive
models and there's a whole bunch of
companies doing products in this field
and the problem with this is that the
data is too fast the data is too big
there are not enough people so we have
these several problems there's the data
prep
problem but the models get obsolete very
quickly you know in the real world we
have high velocity data and the patterns
in the data are constantly changing
so the time you get your models done
it's it's it's
they're invalid anymore and they have to
go and redo them again
and and basically the biggest problem is
there's not enough people who can do
this work
um we're of the belief and i'm certain
of this that the
a large part of the future of data is
going to be the following you're going
to take data from sensors you're going
to stream them directly to
to online models and those online models
are going to go read
directly to actions and and this is it's
we're going to automate the entire
process of course this may look similar
to what brains do and that's how we got
into this space
when i started the momentum we was all
about doing the theory and the brain
stuff we didn't really think about this
but we said okay what are we going to do
with this
this is a good place to apply these
models so the key criteria to do this
kind of streaming data
is you need to have automated model
creation you have to have continuous
learning because the patterns in the
world change
and you have to be able to find temporal
and spatial patterns in the data
it's not good enough to find spatial
correlations you have to look for the
time sequences
in patterns and data so that's what
we've done um
we've created this product called grock
which is an engine for acting on data
streams
here is a conceptual diagram how it
works on the left we have
a stream of records coming in i show
three records there one or more fields
those fields are somewhat structured or
semi-structured data numbers categories
and so on
we run them through a set of encoders
which are like your retina and so on we
turn them into sparse distributed
representations
um i'll tell you a second about that we
then take those parts to
superimpositions we run them through our
cortical learning algorithm
the memory model i just showed you we
get predictions out the other side we
turn those predictions into actions
and then you have a system that
basically learns continuously on streams
of data
um i won't go into total detail but i
know that
some of you will be interested like how
do we encode these fields
into sparse certificate representations
let me give you a brief introduction
imagine i had a number
um a scalar or floating point number or
something like that
and i you can imagine a number line and
i say okay this is oil temperature or
this is energy or
pricing or something like that i want to
turn into sparse distributed
representation
imagine this number goes from zero to
100 and now imagine i i defined some
buckets one buckets from zero to
one to zero to ten others from one to
eleven and others from two to twelve and
so on
and so i have all these overlapping
buckets each is associated with a bit
so if i pick a number on the number line
i'll get 10 activations all 10 one bits
representing 10 things that are sort of
shifted buckets that overlap that one
number so if i pick 20
the number from 19 to 29 will be active
and 18 to 28 will be active and so on
so i have a long number line i have a
bunch of ones so
it's a sparse representation and notice
that when the number increases if i go
from 20 to 21 the 22
as the input one bit drops off and
another bit
at comes on so there's a there's
semantic similarity between 19 and 20
because they share a lot of bits but
they're slightly different
and that's the kind of thing we want to
do anyway we come up with a set of
encoders to do this automatically so you
don't have to think about it
um whereas the user of grok all you have
to do is you have to provide the data
streams
um to us you have to define your problem
what do i want to predict how far in
advance how often
um etc then grok there's a lot of stuff
i'm not going to tell you about here
but essentially it does a parameter
search to figure out the best way of
representing those inputs
it creates models for you it learns
continuously so you just start streaming
the data to it
and then it finds the patterns in the
data if it can and then it outputs
predictions with probability saying okay
it's 30
chance of this and 20 chance of that
type of thing and then we act upon it
there's a lot of um interesting customer
areas we're finding a lot in the energy
space
energy pricing and demand response
product forecasting and network returns
machine efficiencies server lows i'll
give you a couple of examples of this
just to see how this stuff works
uh just in case you're interested i'm
not the software guy here
but our basic architecture running today
on an amazon
cloud we have a rest api people write
apps to it
there's a few a few apps web apps
there's a little quick starting thing
and there's a developer dashboard
we use some some of the modern tools
hadoop but we don't use it for our data
we use it for managing processes and
jobs
anyway you don't need to know this and
grock doesn't have to be running on a
cloud service it'd be running
uh on a dedicated machine too i'll just
give an example in the energy space
demand response in case you know what
demand response is
it turns out that in large energy
consumers are constantly
bidding on the price of their
electricity or energy and they can do
this on an hourly basis on a daily basis
being i'll use this much at this prices
these markets that are going out there
and if people can predict their energy
usage better
they can save a lot of money so it's
something now i'm going to show you a
very simple example here so you can see
it
although not all the examples are so
clean and simple like this here's energy
uses in a building
for seven days and you can see there's
five days and then there's a weekend
where not much is going on
in that in this particular building and
there's some pattern to this
now we feed this to grok and in the in
this particular case the customer wanted
to predict you know
uh well i'll tell you in a moment the
customer wanted to predict uh at
midnight want to predict
hourly what the energy consumption is
going to be for the following day so 24
predictions in a row
and so when i show you the next chart
this is what i'll be doing uh
let's see here so here it is now
relaying the the real versus the
prediction the reds and the prediction
the blue is reality
now i'll warn you you can't really tell
too much by looking like a chart like
this so i'm not like claiming hey isn't
that great it is that great actually
turner the customer is very happy
but um but but you you have to be very
careful when you're trying to
you know judge how well something is
doing but in this case you get a sense
that grock is picking up these patterns
it's learning it very quickly starts
saying hey there's these patterns i see
that it looks like this and it looks
like this
and if those patterns change it quickly
adapts and say well the
new reality is something different um
here's an interesting case where we went
three days into a week
and then there was a holiday there which
we didn't know about or knowing no well
we
wasn't trained on this system and so on
the beginning of the fourth day brock
started saying hey
energy expression start going up and
then it says no it didn't go up it says
oh maybe it's a different pattern it's
like it's like it's predicting a melody
and then a new melody comes along and
says oh i guess i was wrong
it's the new melody and so it basically
falls into a different pattern
where it's predicting the rest of the
week like that so it can adjust very
rapidly
in situations like that um let me give
you another example this is a customer
who is doing video transcoding and they
have customers send them videos and they
have to transcode them in real time and
put them up on the web immediately
and they have a because they have to do
is very rapid they have to have a lot of
servers online all the time most of the
time they're just sitting there doing
nothing
and if they could be they have to have
this extra buffer they could predict the
demand from their customers better
then they could save a lot of money by
uh not having so many services around
so uh this is another situation where
blue is actual red is predicted
this is a much messier pattern you can't
always get this stuff right but i can't
always predict it but the point is can
you do better than any other system
in this case we could and we did a it
looks like we could reduce our cost by
about 15 percent
uh on something like this um
now i'm going to walk you through sort
of internal just a little bit of
maternals
to show you where to look just look at
the thing on the right here don't pay
attention to the stuff on the left it's
just more predictions than actuals
on the right we're looking at an
internal sort of tool we have where
each of those little dots of circles is
there's 2 000 of them
and that's one of our the columns in our
models and the green dots are ones that
were predicted and actually occurred so
this is a prediction we had a single
prediction of 40 green
40 columns 40 bits and um and they
actually occurred it was a single
prediction and a single it was a perfect
match that happens actually more than
you think
here's another example where um we
actually had multiple predictions going
on so the blue circles are
i'm not sure if they look blue to you um
but the blue circles are ones were also
predicted but didn't occur so this is
when we predicted multiple things
the green ones what did occur this is a
perfectly good match because
one of the things we predicted occurred
at this point in time
and then here's one that's sort of a
mixed bag and it doesn't look like you
can see the reds in that well there's
some reds there's a bunch of red circles
on that one
and what's going on here is that some of
the some of the columns were predicted
and occurred some of them predicted it
didn't occur and some things occurred
which weren't predicted and those were
anomalies those were
things that were unexpected and there's
maybe about 25 or so of those red
circles on there
and what that means is that the point of
this is to show that you know prediction
is not a binary thing it's like oh
here's the answer it's a very subtle
thing and even anomalies are subtle
things
i can look at this and say well part of
it was right and part of it was wrong i
could
even ask what parts were wrong and by
what degree and so on and what was the
semantic meaning of the wrongness
and so there's a lot of subtlety that
can be can be picked out of these
internal representations
here's an example where we're using the
anomalies this is looking at
bearing engine oil temperature oil
temperature in a crank
case of a big windmill okay and the blue
line is the temperature fluctuating in
this windmill crankcase
these are very expensive big windmills
offshore and uh and then the bottom the
red line on the bottom here
is basically a sort of a an average a
running average of the
anomaly of of the temporal patterns now
what's
interesting about this is you can see um
yeah on the under the circle there you
can see there's a peak and there's a
couple of peaks in the red which is our
anomaly score
and this occurred not because the oil
temperature got out of range it didn't
get out of range it's just that the
temporal patterns looked unusual
it was like listing a bunch of melodies
i'm now i'm saying notes but
the order of them was wrong and so grog
said this doesn't look normal i haven't
seen this before and so the anomaly
score goes up and that turned out to
correspond to
an event of interest to the to the
windmill manufacturer
okay so now i'm going to end my talk i
have no idea what time it is here how am
i doing on time
i got 10 minutes oh good well then i can
i can wax eloquently
what is that you're going to keep
listening no matter what
well i'm going to run out of things to
say after a while so um
but let me talk about i'm just talking
about the future machine intelligence so
uh you know i i'm excited about the
future of machine intelligence i think
it's gonna be
just amazing um and and people have
different
opinions about this i mean um and i have
a very very
unique opinion about it i'm not trying
to just a lot of other things like i
think you know
um i i want to drive a google
self-driving car
and i'm thrilled that ibm can beat
watson i mean they can beat the jeopardy
and play chess and all this kind of
stuff
but i'm interested in building machines
that work on the way the brain works and
i think there's going to be many many
things
that can be done this way that we can't
do otherwise and it's going to be very
difficult to know
um how this is all going to play out but
i believe that the future machine
intelligence is going to be based on
these principles i was just talking to
you about
and i believe if you take other
approaches you can do interesting things
but it won't really be the core
of intelligence so let's let's just
speculate about i hate talking about the
future because we never really know
what's going to happen
um but but there's some things i can say
right up front
there's a lot more theory that has to be
done here a lot more science so there's
a lot of stuff i didn't tell you about
which we
some of which we know and somewhat in
depth some if we know very little about
there's a lot of other problems
interesting neuroscience and
and information hearing problems i
there's some questions we still have
about how the hierarchy works we did
some experimentation on that
um there's this whole issue of sensory
motor integration it turns out every
region in the neocortex
has a motor output there isn't a motor
output section of your brain
people used to think that way we now
know that every part of your cortex has
a motor output even the
low-level visual parts and so this idea
of how the how the brain
not only perceives in infers and make
predictions
but is also generating motor behavior at
the exact same time
there's all these really interesting
clues to how this works but i don't
understand it yet and no one does
there's a whole issue of about attention
so the point is there's more science
that has to be done here
and it's fun to do the the next thing is
we can talk about what's the embodiment
of these systems
you know today we're doing this on a
simple system it's a cloud-based service
obviously it could be embedded um uh one
interesting idea is
you know the brain has a hierarchy of
memory regions that are all in your head
right that's where they all are they're
on one
sheet of cells but there's no reason
they have to be in one location
and we start thinking about the arrays
of sensors in the world
there's billions and billions there'll
be trillions of sensors in the world and
they're distributed around the world so
it is possible we might build
distributed hierarchies that is i can
have
you can imagine i'll have models of
buildings and cities over here and
models of buildings and cities over here
and then they combine in some other
hierarchical way someplace else and so
the idea that you could
do very clever things with hierarchies
and um
and extracting sort of uber patterns is
very interesting and i really have no
idea how it's going to play out
but i have a feeling it's going to be
important there's clearly a need to
build hardware here
we're doing this in software and we
spend a lot of time doing tricks and
software to make this fast
we have to make this fast um and uh you
know we're modeling large systems of 60
000 neurons and millions of connections
and
but it you know there's a limit to what
we can do here and so for the usual
reasons of speed
cost and power we really want to do
custom hardware on this uh and i've
already in several conversations with
some uh major hardware companies who are
on the experimentation the research side
are looking at this are very interested
in our algorithms
and if we think about it though what
we're trying to do here it's not like
new computers
it's memory there's all memory so it's
new memory architectures
um now one thing that's interesting in
in in this case
since everything is fault tolerant
there's you know you can lose bits you
can lose
columns you can lose anything you know
essentially the system degrades
gracefully so
the whole dynamics of how you go about
designing memory chips could change
with today it's very much on you know
keeping the limit on how many you know
you can't have
more than just a few defects on any chip
well now what if i could say you can
have
one percent of your memory cells be
defective what would that mean in terms
of your process and so on that's very
interesting to think about
of course a large part of the problem
building intelligent machines and
building a brain is interconnection
most of the your brain is connections
the whole white miters connections in
fact
everywhere you look it's mostly
connections it's it's it's neurons
connecting being axons and dendrites
so these don't work very well for chips
chips aren't really good at
massive connections so there's a lot of
problems to be solved there
and again sparsity can come to our
our aid because we don't have to connect
everything to everything we might say
hey it's good enough i only
i'm only able to connect the half the
bits or i'm only able to make a
connection to something
and we can do the sub sampling and
hierarchy so there's a whole series of
things here
which might get us to rethink what it
means to build memory chips
uh and to build computer chips in
general
and then finally what are the
applications that are going to be done
with this
um well you know today
i showed you an example for our first
product it's a prediction anomaly
detection
streaming data engine called grock
that's pretty cool but it's just a
iceberg there's there's what i call the
classics the classics of ai
so most people come they say wow we'll
be able to do vision and language and
speech and so on
and you probably yeah the brain does all
that stuff but i actually don't think
this is where it's going to be
interesting
these to me are problems that can be
probably solved other ways and
and they're not maybe even that
interesting i think the history of
technology has shown us over and over
and over again
that the really cool applications that
come along are not the ones we
anticipated at the time
and i i think that's going to happen
here as well so what are those cool
applications
what are the really big ones um well
i've already told you i don't know
but i can tell you a few things i can
tell you we can make we can make
artificial brains if you want to call it
that way or
machines that work on the principles in
the air cortex we can make them that run
a million times faster than brains
you know brains are pretty slow uh
neurons can't do anything faster than
about five milliseconds
and that's pushing it um so you know
brains are pretty slow and what if we
can make them things around a million or
10 million or 100 million times faster
wow and not get tired that's pretty
interesting we can make them bigger we
can make memory systems that are
much much larger than uh than the human
brain
and and we can also come up with all
kinds of creative sensory arrays that we
didn't have before things that can sense
things that are very small and very
large
to me the goal here is not to build
anything like a robot
it's not to build human-like things it's
not to pass the turing test i have no
interest in that whatsoever
i want to build machines that are useful
for humans and
i if i think about you know um you know
what like what excites me in the world
is knowledge discovery i love learning
new things and
i imagine most of you do too so the idea
that we could have tools that help us
learn new things like having really
really smart physicists to work around
the clock
a million times fast and never get tired
and never eat um that would be pretty
cool you know
and they they have no human desires
there's no point now these are things
that are like sentient beings are going
to take over the world or anything like
that it's just these are just tools for
us
um and if i want to explore the universe
i don't think humans are going to do
that we're not designed for that but we
could build
machines robotic machines that are
intelligent
can can really figure out the world and
we can send them out then they come back
and tell us what's going on out there
so um to me it's like these are the kind
of weird things that could happen
uh and i'm very very excited about i'm
sure it'll be very interesting and i
hope i can live long enough to see some
of it occur
um so what do you want to learn more
information about this well there's a
couple things you can do
uh one on our website there's a white
paper which talks about this
uh what we call the cortical learning
algorithm which is more details about
the algorithm i just told you about
it doesn't show the internals of grock
but it tells you the algorithm you can
read that
you can read my book which alex mentions
on intelligence it's about five years
old now so
it covers sort of the big picture it
doesn't cover the details of the
learning algorithm if you didn't
understand at that time
this talk i'm going to get i'm giving
right now is going to be posted by alex
but you can see a very similar talk i
gave at the international symposium
computer architecture
back in july i think it was it's on the
you it's on
on the web on our website or on youtube
you can just look for jeff hawkins iska
i'm here for the rest of the day i also
have two people with me joe hayashi is a
vp of marketing and matt taylor
who's our manager of web uh services at
uh
at numenta that's an old-time uh strange
loop guy
and old saint louis louie st louie
um so we're gonna be hanging out here
all day we actually actually have a room
over in the hotel
some room over there where where we give
demos if you want to come over there at
the zephyr rocket room
and we can show you what brock's about
and tell you more in details about it
and and there's my email address you're
welcome to send me emails about anything
i respond to all emails
and that's it thank you very much the
question does the system learn like a
child becoming more expert over time
yes it does i mean it's a learning
system so it starts with a memory
structure
but really there's no nothing in it um
and and then as you stream the data and
it starts learning these patterns and
has a very high capacity starts such
adding and adding and adding on top of
it
um we're we're not like a human
i you know we only model this very very
small part of the neocortex one little
layer one little thing it's very small
but um but in a in a human there's a
hierarchy and there's a whole bunch of
learning processes occur over the
hierarchy so like if you learn to play
piano and you practice over and over
again
actually the you you you start at the
higher the hierarchy move it down so
there's a bunch of other things that
humans do when we learn we're not doing
that but basically it's a learning
system
and basically there's no program the
program is just modeling the memory
you stream data in and it starts
learning the patterns and it will forget
too
if you don't see a pattern in a long
time there as it fills up it sort of
forgets the things that you haven't seen
in a long time
yeah i'll take this question right front
yeah so the question is a lot of the
a lot of the technologies discussed here
have community groups that
and they have their ways of getting
together and like forums and so on
uh do we have anything like this um
that's a great question for matt
and joe i think later you know we love
to do that we have
right now we're in a private beta and
this is very difficult stuff to get
running it's still difficult to get
ready
um we didn't feel like this leashing it
on everyone it's very hard to understand
what the hell is going on
inside of all this stuff so we want to
move in more of a an open direction but
right at the moment we're
we're in a private beta and the code is
not available to other people
there are people out there by the way in
the white paper there's pseudo code
for the algorithms and we've had several
independent implementations of this
around the world um but i don't know if
there's any there's not
at the moment much organized activity
i'm looking for
math to say yes or no you know maybe not
uh i'd we love to have it well come and
talk to us more about it
uh it's we're trying to match the
reality of a startup company that has to
make them
have to make a profit at some point in
time we've been going along for a long
time without making profit so
we're trying to you know get to the
point where we're stable business
and then um then we can spend more time
in that sort of community aspect
but you know one of my personal goals is
to be a catalyst for machine
intelligence
meaning i don't i'm not interested in
just building a business i'm interested
in
i'm doing this because i want people i
want opportunities like this to speak to
people like you
and i'm doing this because i'm not
trying to sell a product i'm trying to
get other people
excited about this and it's a very big
challenging task it takes quite a while
to really understand deeply all the
things i'm talking about here
it's going to be very many years or this
is going to play out this is not a very
short-term thing
so yes it's the ultimate goal is to
really build a very very large community
of people working on this
uh and i'm just going about it in the
best way i can which is a piecemeal and
and it's very very small right now yeah
i'm gonna take
i'm gonna take a few minutes to this
gentleman first here
the question is how sparse do things
have to be before it turns all
yellow um you know what we've done a lot
of experimentation on sparsity right
trying to figure out how sparse things
have to be there's a trade-off
um in general you you want to have
enough bits active
that you have a distributed
representation so that if you only had
one bit active you'd have what they call
a grandmother cell and the system
wouldn't be reliable you won't have
enough bits active
and yet um you don't want to be you want
to be very sparse because
there's advantages come from being very
sparse and there's advantages coming to
have enough bits active
and that's why you have to have very
large representations um
we've done experiments trying to run our
systems down to as little as 500 columns
versus 2 000 columns
and that's sort of borderlines things
start falling apart you really can't
you can't you can't have enough bits
active and be sparse enough
um so um you can make so
we've you can be anywhere in the in the
five percent to
one percent of your cells active but you
have to have a certain number of cells
active
otherwise you can't do the the sub
sampling and so on
um the question about the number of
yellow bits is like how you don't want
to predict too many things if
i predicted everything then all the all
the cells become
predictive um in the in the brain
there's a lot of inhibitory functions i
didn't talk about all this stuff
is based on these inhibitory neurons
which basically keep things at certain
levels
so what will happen in the brain is
everybody's trying to predict all at
once but the inhibition just basically
shuts it off at some percentage
um so all the cells are going to be
trying to predict at some level
but the inhibition just lets the top
predictors go so you don't have to worry
about the system
um predicting too many things if you
will uh we can adjust that
very easily you can just eat the brain
just by you just dial it up and down
um by the way just a little side if
you're following all this uh
what i imagine is happening when you
when you look like a cloud and someone
says what do you see in that cloud
and and you look at the client i see a
cloud they said oh don't you see an
animal
well what i think is happening there is
that you're not really having
those those there's not enough of those
predictions occurring you don't have
enough yellow bits if you will um
and you're lowering the threshold saying
i'll just keep lowering the threshold
until something pops out
and then you go oh there's a dog i
really think that's exactly what's
happening when you do it when you're
looking at something like that
all right i'm gonna take we're gonna be
around so i'm gonna take one more
question i'm gonna take the person
in the back there who's in the backpack
yeah
yeah i think the question is um is this
it seems there might be a fair amount of
undeterministic
uh behaviors in this system and if we
learn anything interesting about that
um well um well it is determination
there's a there's a bunch of random
processes and if you give the same
random seeds and the same data and
exactly the same thing it'll actually
generally oh actually not anymore
because i think the crazy stuff on the
the hadoop and all that stuff gets it
all messed up the
scheduling gets it so
in theory it's deterministic um in
practicality it's not okay
and we do have random seeds which vary
but we also have the way we
we we we spread this a bunch of
processes and so on you end up
you never really you know practically
it's not deterministic um
so this is worrisome because you run the
same experiments twice you sometimes get
slightly different errors it makes it
very difficult to
debug uh it's very it's very very
difficult in systems like this to know
how well it's doing
you know is it is that a good prediction
or not prediction what's your ground
truth and how do you even judge it and
most
even labeled data doesn't have the kind
of data we typically really want
um so um this you're you're touching on
an area which makes it very difficult to
work on these systems
i don't think we've learned anything uh
dramatic other than it makes it
difficult to work on these systems
um but there's no no amazing insights
that come out of this thing obviously
when you get to something that's
sufficient
it's interesting you know because this
is very interesting phil i'll end on
this interesting philosophical thought
that you know in theory it should be
deterministic because
the way we're doing this here it's just
code is running it's important but
in in a real brain of course there's so
much going on um the cells are
random they're sarcastic um there's all
kinds of weird crap happening in your
brain there's no way in the world it's
deterministic
and and so you're basically looking for
attractors and that's
but even in our first implementation our
simple invitation in grok
it is no longer deterministic because of
this the complexity is the way we've
implemented it on the web
um and uh that makes it already we've
lost the determinism in the whole thing
um and i think that's never we're never
going to turn around and go back but um
i don't think we've learned anything
deeper than that um anyway again the
three of us are going to be around today
and uh we'll be hanging out in the lobby
here for a little while then you can
come by the room over in the hotel if
you anytime and
into the evening i guess i don't know
how it will be there to seven
and you can chat with us more again
thank you very much for your time